we've lost control we used to have
control of the streets when I was in the
job hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Frances foster i'm konstantine
kissin and this is a show for you if
you're bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
a retired police officer of 31 years and
a leading law and order campaigner who
specializes in gun and knife crime
Norman Brennan welcome to trigonometry
good morning to you thank you very much
for coming we really appreciate your
time for anyone who doesn't know you
just tell us briefly who you are how are
you where you are what's been your
journey through life that's taking you
to this chair well as you introduce me
I'm a retired police officer 31 years I
joined at the age of 19 I was very
streetwise when I joined the job I'd
teamed up with different mates of mine
done a bit of boxing done different jobs
was a butcher drove lorries done various
jobs and I reached a stage when I was 19
that you know you could go one of two
ways
I was liaising web we've made some were
criminals believe it or not and others
weren't and even the criminals were
characters they weren't bad bad guys but
I could see then going down the wrong
path and like a lot of people if you
hang around with that lot might find
yourself being drawn into problems and I
remember one particular time I'd had a
rail with a large lot of guys and I
walked into a pub and I was on my own
and it was a massive lot and I was
looking for somebody that had torch my
moped and I said I'll be back the
following week to sort it out
and I went back the following week on my
own took no mates and it was sorted out
but the guy that talked to my bike
didn't want to deal with it one of his
mates who thought he was quite tasty did
fortunately I could look after myself
very well and the little scuffle pretty
bit more than a scuffle but no weapons
there after I came out on top but of
course I was outnumbered so I took off
and not long later I actually went back
with my team and fortunately it didn't
kick off thereafter but I just thought
what the hell am i doing my life you
know if I get involved in this sort of
thing I'm gonna get in a lot of trouble
but I wasn't that one to ever back down
and I always wanted to be a police
officer and I thought this is not the
right way to go so I joined the police
service at the age of 19 well you've got
the big the better team now police
officer you can go in there and kick
everybody some people say we could do it
lawfully but that's actually what we do
the majority of the science but yeah I
was 19 years of age I was positioned all
over London my force was the British
Transport Police and it'd been accepted
by the mayor but I was actually - sent
to me it's too short at that particular
time and lots of people were not joined
in other forces so I just basically
stayed with my force I met great guys
great women and it was a good teamwork
and throughout the whole of my 31 years
I worked in various positions various
stations I was on a shield unit did my
training with the met over in Hounslow
was on a public called a squad travelled
around the country travelled around
London with the shield unit I then went
into CID as a young detective did
training with the senior DC's and it was
quite funny when I first joined the job
there was these old sweats that used to
come in like Jack Regan and Dennis
Warren and and there was one thing that
everybody has always said in the job is
the first thing those detectives said is
the job is [ __ ] and it's quite funny
actually now because even now if you
actually see t8 or the TJ F the job is
even people say that now
I always remembered that an awful bloody
oh you must be very disillusioned but
that was just the character it was the
sort of things that people said in the
job so I then went on to various
positions so him I was on a robbery
squad for six years in North London I
took an interest in victims regularly
victims were not given the help and the
support that they rightly deserved and
brown about the 1980s police officers
were being very seriously assaulted the
push in the punch had to become the kick
and people would be an attack with
weapons and in particular knives and I
recall in the early 80s I just come back
from taking the sergeant's exam and I
was traveling through Victoria which has
normally got quite a lot of police
officers there but that particularly
night all the officers were out on
football duties at football matches out
on public order vehicles and there was
one female officer pleased to call them
WP sees now but we're politically
correct now everybody PC young deke
oddly and there was three pickpockets
that I actually came across and I
attempted to rest two of them all three
of them but I grabbed hold or two of
them and I got very seriously assaulted
I went I kicked the door of the Nick and
said look I need some assistance
but unbeknownst to me there was one lone
female officer there so I was very
seriously assaulted rushed the hospital
that night I mean obviously once a
police officers assaulted certainly in
those days everybody attends you know
canteens empty but the canteens weren't
full everybody was out on other duties
so I ended up in hospital I was in
intensive care overnight with a double
suspected fracture the skull was in
hospital for about ten days and I came
out and the injuries were such the part
of my nose had been dislodged and I had
a quite serious surgery so I was off
duty for three and a half months
recovering but because I had to have
reconstructive surgery over the
in three years I had to have a further
eight months off duty parts of my nose
had to be cut out and re structured so
as a young PC of still enthused with the
job but I realized the enormity of the
assaults on place
so I'd over a year off sick my force
were fantastic my colleagues were
absolutely brilliant and I'd only been
back on duty for a number of weeks and I
was an area car driver and I was out
with a new acting inspector that night
showed him around London and then my own
sergeant joined me and we just had to
drive out early hours of the morning it
was a hot summer's morning in early
September
remember dealing with the publican and a
cab driver as we were driving through
Victoria they had a bit of a rel we
resolved that one was drunk the other
one wasn't happy that his fare wasn't
paid life was good I had a terrific
girlfriend on the firm at a time I
played rugby at a very high level and
life was okay I was looking at getting
promoted within the police and as I
drove down towards Chelsea bridge I saw
this black guy running across the road
followed by uniformed officers there
were quite a distance behind them and I
used to be able to clear two hundred
meters just outside the UK record and
even in full uniform I could clear a
distance very quickly so I parked my
area car up on the road because I know
they didn't just want to speak to him
ask him if he's got a licence or they
want to give him a parking ticket this
was quite a serious incident I thought
two o'clock in the morning 2:30 in the
morning robbery burglary 10 theft of
vehicle so I parked my car across the
road of tight street believe it or not
and I got out my car and I chased this
guy down tight Street but all the cars
apart literally tight against each other
so I couldn't get him and he was very
fast as well so I run down the middle of
the road and I saw a gap up the up the
towards the end of the road so I run
between two of the cars and I grabbed
hold of him I didn't have my baton out
or anything like that
because it was dark I didn't see that he
had a knife and it had it actually
committed three aggravated burglaries
which means that you break into
properties armed with a weapon something
a householder it's very concerned about
and rightly so anyway I grabbed hold of
him and the next thing I felt was a bit
like a stitch in my stomach he - he
stabbed me no I say put the blade in and
it was it was quite strange because
everything slows down when you've been
stabbed and hundreds of families have
asked me what it's like and it's quite
funny I looked down and I only had my
summer shirt on and I could see all the
blood literally coming out of my chest
and my sergeant was chasing after him
and I said he's got a blade but I
couldn't really speak I was sort of
winded if it's like and a lot of people
say what's it like when you've been
stabbed and is serious and it's the
loneliest feeling in the world because
you can't talk nobody necessarily knows
exactly what's happened because
everything's happening quick pretty much
like all the stabbings in London
nowadays it happened so quick nobody can
really gather the enormity except the
victim and I remember the I was stealing
but I'll put my hand here and I could
kit I kept seeing all the blood coming
over my fingers and I thought this is
real bad and I actually thought [ __ ] I'm
gonna die I don't talk about it often so
yeah and that happened just after I had
recovered from the previous assault and
I was in hospital for ten days off sick
for over twelve weeks and I didn't
recover from that one and I thought
something's got to be done too many
police officers are being assaulted
their lives are being destroyed some
were not some were murdered and I'd
recovered and the gift that I've always
been given since that day is this is
that I've done thousands have been used
probably ten thousand interviews and
what people don't understand is people
can say whatever they like to me people
have tried they destroyed my career
the backbone to stand up and challenge
the establishment is that when you face
death then you survived every day is a
gift
so whatever anybody ever does thereafter
they can't hurt you more than what
somebody nearly did anyway get him back
to the point is I got demoralized I got
depressed and I started losing the will
to be a police officer you know I was
young I put the first down to bad
experience the second one really took
the wind out of us literally and I got
very demoralized so what I did is I went
to the police service I said somebody's
got to do something about this so I set
up protect the protectors you always
hear the sign protect the protectors and
I went to the police review and I said
to them something's got to be done about
assaults on police the sentences are
disgraceful the assaults are as bad and
they said well normally what happens is
is that we run your story by your chief
constable or your false just to make
sure happy I said you don't do that I
said if they secondly they set me but
somebody has got to bring this to the
public's attention but government's
attention the criminal justice system
and also chief constables so I was a
second police officer in history to
break from the ranks and demand the
police were protected the original one
was a police inspector in 1919 he was
disillusioned with how the police were
being neglected and failed and he broke
from the ranks he was sacked but the
Police Federation was thereafter
launched so that was the first major
campaign that are launched is protect
the protectors giving police a voice
give Him police the protection that they
need and it was pretty successful the
government done a u-turn on giving
police side-handle baton I also
campaigned for stablish resistant vests
which is what we got I did the
tomorrow's world if you remember that
program I was there advising them on
there and also see a spray so for the
first time since World War two
police were given more than just a small
baton and a whistle they actually had
proper battens stab resistant vests and
sear spray and these were these were the
type of equipment that would allow us to
defend ourselves and tackle criminals
that did what they did to me what an
amazing story and thank you so much for
coming to talk to us I'm guessing this
is the first time in the history of
trigonometry you haven't got a jock no
banter from you you talk about the job
being [ __ ] right this was what people
would say at the time yeah I don't think
there's certainly in living memory
there's been a time where it seems like
crime and the streets of London knife
crime gun crime the things that you
talked about is worse than it is now it
seems like it's terrible doesn't it we
hear about people being stabbed as you
were shot all the time I mean it's a
daily occurrence now what is going on in
the streets of our cities we've lost
control we used to have control of the
streets when I was in the job and I've
been retired ten years now we actually
went out in numbers we had the numbers
we had the squads and if a job come in
for example where I remember taking a
Crimestoppers call and I think I knew
who the informant was but it come
through anonymously and this guy had
attacked his own mother father I think
it was or yeah and punched her in the
face not about nine teeth out it was a
dangerous dangerous man and I recalled
taking there and I turn around and I
said to the day I write this guy I know
where he is
I've got an address we need to Nick him
he said right I want two teams out who
wants to come in tomorrow morning six
o'clock
any rest day workings which you know
were always great always added up to the
CID paid l buy a pint or two when we
celebrated getting a good job down or
also when we commiserate when we lost a
job which we knew we should have won but
the point was we had two teams together
we all went home that night went a bed
four o'clock in the morning we were all
up two cars got the equip
we needed had the right people we needed
we didn't [ __ ] about in those days
nowadays you've got pretty soft plea
service some pretty tough ones in those
days you know we weren't frightened of
challenging anyone we knew we had the
big boys with firearms if we needed them
we knew that we had the clout and the
numbers to go around and we did not [ __ ]
about we actually did the job didn't
beat him up occasionally there was a
very violent arrest but we had to use
the violence in response to the violence
that was often portrayed to us anyway on
that particular occasion I remember I
where I actually had one of the side
idle battles on trial because I was the
lead campaigner for him so I took that
one with me and I remember the neck the
following morning we put the door in
other guys went round aback because we
make sure they don't escape from windows
and doors and I realized that you know
ye if you can even beat your own mother
up and she would very seriously G be
aged but the point was we had the
numbers to do the job we had the will to
do the job and we wanted to do it the
sad reality today is over the last 10
years we've lost almost 22,000 frontline
police officers Theresa May had a bit of
a dream job at the Home Office nobody
really challenged her and what she
decided to do because of austerity is to
cut policing but she cut policing at a
time when the mood and the change on the
streets of Britain had reached a stage
where guns and knives were being used at
will people were getting involved in an
argument in a pub for argument sake or
in a part in a high street in a club and
within minutes they have a gun and we
had we had to deal with that and more
people was carrying knives more people
were carrying guns and we we need to be
able to deal with that so what Theresa
May did is she started reducing the
police service and it's a chap called
Sir Tom Windsor
and he was her hatchet man and it was
just before I retired from the police
service he came in and started making
all the cuts changing the discipline
code and he completely demoralized the
British police service a few years later
as the cuts started to bite into resume
and I think it was May 2015 she went to
the police Federation conference and
they highlighted to her the concerns
that I've been highlighting ever since I
broke from the ranks in the police I
would do hundreds of interviews in my
own time I took a two-year career break
to work primarily with victims because
after I broke from the ranks and
launched protect the protectors the
public used to speak to me all over
London when I was off duty and they said
saw you on the television the other day
GMTV sky whatever it is you really care
about what's going on the streets you
give the police a voice that we haven't
got as victims so strangely enough I
actually launched the victims of crime
trust so I saw Road to horses I spoke up
for the police and also there I spoke up
for the victims of crime one of the
points you made to me Norman is that a
lot of people are living in fear now in
our communities to tell us a little bit
more about that because as you say you
deal with victims as well as what's put
with the police officers well every
every time there's a knife attack it
causes fear causes fear amongst the
gangs which are not a hundred percent
responsible the gang sort of the gang
stabbings shootings are about fifty five
percent and forty five percent come from
other types of crime but the thing is
there are so many gangs now I think
you've got almost 200 in London and four
thousand believe it or not nationally
and they're up to about a hundred strong
many carry knives some carry guns
mainly they carry knives but there's a
fear amongst those or fear less
depending which actually you use and
these predominately children were
anywhere between 13 and 19 early
twenties have no value of life
we'll carry a gun not many but some do
or have access to a gun many will carry
these dreadful looking knives that we so
often see on social media and in answer
to your question why is there a fear is
because it's happening too often I mean
once you would say is too often but
these are happening thousands and
thousands of times and the sad reality
is now children are killing children
and in London which I police and I
predominantly police high ethnic areas
so I understand that their their
concerns about policing about the
criminal justice system there are
attitudes their likes their dislikes
their contempt for us sometimes and each
other but every time you have a stabbing
and somebody dies it ricochets around a
community and when you have a stabbing
where somebody dies in different parts
of London the Ricochet continues and
it's a bit like a cancer it spreads and
the fear of knife crime or being
involved in it or coming across it now
control some people's lives
you know they won't walk out on the
streets uncertain after dark for example
they won't want to walk the streets in
certain areas where there's high knife
crime but these the this knife crime has
caused the fear that I've never ever
seen in 41 years of dealing with the
criminal justice system and it's out of
control and if you go back to what I was
just talking about the Police Federation
I broke from the ranks all those years
ago on the I think it was the 13th of
December 2004 I was in full uniform
there were some of the highest profile
homicide families who had been stabbed
to death and I launched knives destroy
lives I went to number 10 Downing Street
I thought that get sacked again but
because a third of the police services
side my original petition politicians
and chief constables were loathed to
sack us so I could basically do what I
wanted within reason and I always made
sure it was done professionally and you
know with respect but I went to number
10 Downing Street auditor and I
predicted a knife crime epidemic
two or three years beforehand I
predicted the gun crime epidemic and in
my penultimate paragraph to the Queen
which I still got now I said let your
government gets his act together gun
crime is going to be epidemic on our
streets and more and more children are
going to be using guns and I said within
two years and I've got the letter and I
can prove it within two years I was
almost spot-on that was what happened
so back in 2013 I'd been stabbed and I
took a very keen interest in knife crime
and day in and day out are dealt with
offenders I dealt with victims are dealt
with a public plus I advised the whole
country through national media often I
could speak to millions of people at a
time where they thought they couldn't
use false they couldn't do this what can
they do there I used to be out although
I knew the law inside out I didn't want
to bore them with acts and sections I
told them what they could and what they
couldn't actually do but there we were
and here we are all these years on these
stabbings are happening at will and only
a week or two weeks ago I think there
was five six stabbings murders in in a
five day period then the following week
there were four shooting murders along
with stabbing murders so in answer to
your question all of these cause fear
and not only that is that every time
certainly we with in policing know every
time it's a gang-related crime within
minutes or hours the aggrieved gang that
has just lost a member or just that a
member very seriously as injured will be
looking for retaliation they go out on
the tube mopeds pedal cycles cars you
name it motorbikes mobile they will go
out looking for immediate revenge so the
public rightly would say I hope you the
police are predicting on what they're
going to do but when you've got 200
gangs in London alone up to a hundred
strong we can't watch them all and we
have lost nearly 22,000 police officers
and Theresa May has probably almost
ghal handedly with the help of Sir Tom
Windsor who was actually knighted after
he crippled the police service and is
now a Majesty's inspector of
Constabulary which just rubs all our
noses in it
they have all but destroyed British
police any people say Norman destroyed
British policing no we see them but
they're still out and about what do you
know not really you don't see them you
don't right um I was gonna ask because
this question because this has been
something that people routinely use the
critiques silicon how much
responsibility does he have as London
Mayor for what is happening on our
streets he has some responsibilities
he's obviously like the police crime
Commissioner for the Met Police but the
government and the ones have got the
real big purse strings
the unfortunate thing was Sadiq Khan
this is out of touch yes he's only all
niches about air pollution which I know
is very important and he seems to look
after his own little groups that he
likes and he's all but ignored knife
crime gun crime and we within policing
and the criminal justice system
certainly campaigners like myself look
to people like him to stand up speak out
and put in a plan of action to make sure
the streets of London are safe and the
sad reality is all we get is window
dressing we get a nice door get nice
windows they've got lovely plants in
them and they've got lovely curtains you
actually open the curtains and open
those windows behind them is chaos on
the streets of London
so what Sadiq aunt does is he says yes I
know there's a problem but don't worry
do you realise both he and Theresa May
when she was a home secretary wanted to
take the Metropolitan Police to court so
they would be forced to reduce stop and
search and here we are now in 2019 both
Sadiq Khan and Theresa May are almost
pleading the police service to carry out
more stop and searches because within
policing we said ok with stop it the
police are not backed up and when you
actually look at the realities getting
back to your knife crime is certainly
within the black community and the
reason I talk about the black community
if that is what is happening in London
and anytime anybody wants to talk about
a race issue or a black issue they're
accused of being racists well by telling
people the truth as I say by telling
people the facts you'll share in what
our concerns are because often there are
people in the black community that share
our concerns but they're also the anti
police groups and community leaders some
of them that just will never work with
the police so that is that that is the
difficulty that we've always had but
just get him back to that point just
look at all these parents that have had
a son stabbed to death he's gone out 2
o'clock in the morning four o'clock in
the morning 14 years of age 16 years of
age with his mates often gang members
than themselves and has lost his life
and he's taken to a mall tree a mall
trees have filled now with kids all over
London and other parts of Britain for
children they've often not got a name
although they have got a name what
they've got is a tag around their big
toe with their name and a number
so many of these kids have got numbers
and when somebody's murdered a police
officer known as a family liaison
officer will go to the mall tree with
the parents to ID the child if they
haven't been ID'd a hospital which is
where often happens and there is a child
that was alive six hours ago there is a
child that that parent was looking
forward to growing up doing well in life
settling down having children and
hopefully being for them being there for
them in their old age and there they are
dead so you've got parents now
planning funerals rather than futures so
they in their briefs they are falling
into the arms of my colleagues in the
family liaison units and senior
investigating officers pleading with us
please make my son the last one so the
onus is on us we have to go out and we
have to try and make sure that that son
is the last one but we know that their
son is not going to be the last one
because dealing with the crimes that we
have to deal with we've so few officers
and there are some people that hate the
police so much that they would never
ever work with us we know that there are
many people in the black community that
want rid of these gang members they want
rid of these knifings and shootings so
getting back to your point 20 minutes
ago
there is a fear of crime and being
victim of a crime that I've never known
if 41 years of policing and I've looked
right back to the first world war I've
never seen crime a violent crime gun
crime knife crime as bad as it is now
but the thing that concerns me in a
people more is that we with emplacing
have the inability to effectively deal
with it and reassure the public and I
think we should be honest with the
public if we can't cope we should tell
the public we can't cope we should tell
them the reasons and if anybody ever
believes that we don't care I didn't
join the police service and nor does
tens of thousands of others to persecute
motorists to stop and search black
suspects that is a small part of the job
that we joined to do but it's an
important part of job nowadays because
we have to try and stop these children
killing each other and the sad reality
is and I'm ashamed to say it
because a lot of people do listen to us
whether they take notice or not I don't
know but we've lost the streets of
Britain
we've lost the streets of London and for
any police officer retired police
officer
say there who has a passion about law
and order as I do I dedicated most of my
life to policing the streets of London's
police in Britain basically and for me
to be saying this now is just like a
nightmare I never thought in my wildest
of dreams that I would ever be saying to
anybody that ever wants to listen as
someone that is a professional law and
order campaigner and represents huge
numbers of people that the police have
lost the streets of Britain Norman you
seem to stink or you seem to say that
it's a lot of this is down to austerity
is it just cuts to the police service or
there are the factors to blame as well
it is is basically that that is the
starting point that is the heartbeat
that is the heartbeat of where it all
started
I mean city carne again said just a
couple of days ago although this will be
going out sometime later so it might be
a number of weeks ago he said a lot of
the problems are down to poverty well I
disagree I disagree it's not down to
poverty at all after World War two you
had a country that fault to keep us safe
had fought for rights hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of young men and
some women lost their lives to give us
the freedoms that we've got today which
often abused but my point is they were
on ration books then they didn't have
flash cars iPhones flat-screen TVs the
pubs and the freedoms that they've got
now there was what I would say was
poverty now you've got kids with the
latest trainers they've got their
iPhones they got cars they smoke they
buy their drugs it's not to do with
poverty it's to do with the freedom of
being able to do what they want to do
and some have chosen to commit crime
they've chose chose to blight the lives
of others and some of these kids as
which which really concerns me deeply is
they have no value of life and it
frightens me because if you have no
value of life
it means that you don't care if you lose
your own you don't care if you lose well
if somebody else is you take somebody
else's life and in seconds you can stab
somebody and you will be serving 20 25
years in prison and you would have taken
somebody's life and often it's because
you're standing on the wrong side of the
road you've shown a bit of disrespect
there's been a bit of drill music you've
taunted each other on social media I've
even represented families I'm enough not
over a thousand families personally
they've had somebody murdered in Britain
I used to represent and very good
friends we saw a pain damn Ilona Taylor
Denis Bolger Leslie and Downey's family
murdered by Myra Hindley and Ian Brady
I've met these people I've stayed with
them I understand the enormity of losing
a child and the public done they say how
dreadful it is and we spoke a bit
earlier on which I'll clarify now the
public asked us why doesn't somebody do
something why doesn't it change why does
it have to be this bad and the sad
reality is and this is me basically
having a bit of pop at the public it's
because the public are apathetic the
public could cause change on a Monday
you've got issue a this has been a
shooting another child has been shot
dead on the Tuesday something else
happens you know you've got Donald Trump
saying something quite outrageous
sending a tweet that's every day
exactly but my point is all the issues
that we were the issues we had a concern
with on the Monday by the Friday have
been forgotten and the reason why
thousands of people say Norman surely if
the government know it's that bad they
would do something about it and I'd say
that sounds pretty sensible and
straightforward but let me tell you how
it works the government are like a
formidable castle they're not stupid
they know the psychology of society and
they know that the issues that a lot of
people were concerned with on Monday
will be gone and changed by the Friday
we never focus on one particular issue
so when people say why aren't they're
all more police why aren't the courts
doing their job why then the sentences
fit the crime it's because we never
concentrate on one single issue it's a
bit like when you get somebody coming in
to become the new prime minister they
want or even a political party the MPs
will make dozens and dozens of promises
to lure you into hook you in to vote for
them and then for the next three to five
years
everybody scratching their heads and
their bums saying what about all those
things you promised and that is the
scenario the government are very good on
psychology if ever we could get the
whole of Britain to say stop what
happens on Monday we will concentrate on
we will make sure that the government
listen they fund it for example that
they must say we want our 22,000 police
officers back Ben in addition we want
10,000 more and people say well hang on
a minute why do you want that 10,000
more well after the Charlie the Charlie
libera the journalists that were killed
in Charlie Hebdo sorry Charlie Hebdo
after they I think it was about nine or
twelve journalists were shot dead over
there
I did the sky interviews and when I was
doing the interviews the French police
or the French government said we are
going to increase our police
establishment by 10,000 we knew within
mi5 mi6 in the anti-terrorist court we
knew that Britain would be hit at some
time in the future so instead of
increasing the British police
establishment by 10,000 we reduce them
by almost 22,000 so when you look out
there now we can't deal with gun crime
knife crime and violent crime we do a
fantastic job on stopping terrorists but
the real reality is is that under this
government and I am NOT politically
motivated I am politically homeless if
this stuff government done great I tell
you but this government under Teresa may
has put this country a great risk not
only by terrorism because we haven't got
the numbers to do it although we
certainly have put the funding there but
criminals now can walk the streets drive
the streets walk into people's houses at
will shoot them stab them beat them up
steal their cars steal their bikes make
their lives of misery and walk off or
drive off laughing and we can hardly do
anything about it I'm angry about it I'm
ashamed about it and I think the public
need to be told the truth that the
police joined the police to keep the
peace to interact with them keep them
safe and challenge the good the bad guys
we don't unfortunately we don't do any
of them what about the social factors
you and I talked before the interiors
well about a guy we had on the show dr.
Tony Saul who was talking about the
breakdown as a family particularly in
the black community where he's from and
he was talking about the fact that a lot
of these kids are growing up without
fathers and they don't have a strong
male role model they don't have anyone
checking their worst impulse at home
they don't have someone to show them how
to be a man in the world do you think
that's an issue that causes crime as
well oh absolutely absolutely I mean
when I was in the robbery squad for six
years I worked round the clock on
dealing with Roberts armed robbers not
as not as many armed robberies but that
was part of our remit on my squad but it
was street robberies at gunpoint and
predominantly at knifepoint and I used
to remember when we used to drive a
juvenile home because a lot of more very
young and we used to knock on the door
of a housing estate Stonebridge Park
Acton you name it all over London not
any particular place and we said knock
on a door mum used to come to the door
and we used to look and see there were
two or three other children there and we
say by the way he's on bail now he's got
to come back to
the police station with making further
inquiries do you know your son pulled a
knife out on someone today if he stabbed
them they probably would have been kept
in custody and he terrified them and mum
wasn't nonchalant but it's as though I
can't cope and we used to drive back to
the police station and we say to each
other in the car what chances he got you
know and what has happened is and the
psychology of a lot of youngsters is is
the dad likes having sex and often he
likes having sex with a number of women
no responsibility so children get into
this world not wanted not planned they
become part of sex what most people that
have sex with take precautions or if
they want children they would have
thought I want a child and I want a
child because I want our lives to be
better I want us to pass on to the next
generation a child that's loved once it
educated nurtured these kids are none of
them and what often happens is they
start off when they're like 10 or 11
walking around the housing estates and
what they do is they meet like-minded
individuals and because dad's often not
been around they see these other kids as
part of their family often it will the
crime will start with bullying on the
school playground robbing people are
taking people's dinner money away often
enough there then be excluded mum can't
cope so when they're excluded they're
walking the streets it then becomes cash
point thefts stealing money off of
people that come from cash points and
then they get known by older gang
members have been pretty streetwise and
they're recruited to protect the turfs
and before they know it they've been
drawn into a world that they've really
almost no nothing they got nobody loved
them nobody wants them there's nothing
to do they've got energy they've
and that's why they served the last ten
years we've got lost generation and the
sad reality is they form the gangs that
I spoke to you a bit about earlier on
they have that they have no values but
they actually feel that the people that
like them that need them want them that
they get something from are like-minded
children so they become a unit they
become a family unit of criminals and
we've got to disperse these family units
of criminals and show them there is
another way and we got to invest in
their futures because these this
generation that we're breeding are going
to be handing over to the next
generation and if carrying a gun
carrying a knife stabbing somebody to
death robbing people at knifepoint
breaking into their homes raping people
doing exactly what they want to do
knowing that there are no police to do
anything about it and even our cults the
Youth Justice Board that magistrates the
judges they have all become social
workers so getting right back to the
beginning of this interview who cares
about the public who cares about the
public safety who cares about the
victims the victims that have been left
behind often with broken lives maimed
they've had items stolen in a burglary
that can never be replaced it will
remain with them forever
the young female that lives on her own
maybe your underwear drawer has gone
through being gone through by people
she's deems as grubby hands are they
gonna come back next time in raper she
will throw her clothes away often if she
can she will move mum and dad may insist
it sister pani who cares about the
public and who cares about the victims
we have almost taken that pendulum and
swung it in the favor of the criminal
element and that pendulum has stuck in
the roof and if society wants to see a
safer Britain a better Britain a Britain
where the police patrol and rule the
streets on behalf of society because
don't
gay police are not Robocop's they're not
born as I said earlier on just to knit
motorists to stop black people they join
a job they're the public the public are
the police the police are the public and
everybody has got to remember that we're
not infallible we hurt we cry we bleed
and sometimes protect in society we die
and too many police officers now are
being assaulted pretty much like I was
all those years ago and we've got a
criminal justice system that cares more
about the criminal and their rights and
we hear about it all the time but I'm
not here is that I've got nothing to
gain by being here apart from telling
people the truth the truth that they
never ever hear because chief constables
are never gonna tell you we've got a
knife crime we can't cope only a year
ago cressid a dick she waited for a sort
of respite period about six to eight
weeks where the stabbings had gone down
and she came out and said we've got a
problem with knife crime but it's not a
crisis the next day and the day after
there was about four or five stabbing
murders so police chief constables crime
commissioners they are not going to come
on national television or in the media
and tell you the truth they are going to
tell you what they think you ought to
know but I think as a caveat to this
part of the interview is if you're
honest with the public and you tell them
the truth they will respect you more for
it and they will be more willing to work
with you to cause change but the more we
hide the true facts from the public and
it's difficult to hide it from them now
because they see on a daily basis how
bad it is they're less we as a team are
going to make it change and that the
pointer for this is this is whilst the
public the police that government the
criminal justice system are all blaming
each other for problems that we're all
partly responded for who is
concentrating on kids killing each other
on homeowners frightened that somebody's
going to break into their home or being
a victim of crime when all we do is
argue about who's responsible and we
concentrate on the offenders if we could
cut the fuel off for those that are
committing crime it means that we can
take a lot of them away from the bad
sort of things in life that they feel
sort of gives them some hope nay's crime
we increased police numbers and
concentrate on those that are not
prepared to learn and the cohesion of
everyone working together instead of
blaming each other might just be the
start of the answer that everyone is
looking for Norman we had Matthew Paris
on who as you as you know is a former
Conservative MP and when we were talking
about knife crime because I put these
same questions to him he believed that
knife crime was a fad or is a fad and it
will soon die out where do you stand on
that he's a politician isn't he former
politician former young I know
journalists now yeah well I've been a
police officer for 31 years I've been
involved in the criminal justice system
for 40 years I've probably done in the
region of 10,000 interviews in the
national media not because I'm just
angry because I care and I've researched
all of my subjects I sometimes know that
the police get things wrong have we
stopped black people in the past for no
reason at all I'm sure we have you know
we are not infallible but the point is I
understand what is happening in the
criminal justice system what is
happening in the real world I've dealt
with the public I've dealt with the
victims and I've dealt with police in
the criminal justice system all the
agencies connected within the criminal
justice system and in answer to his
comment of it Safed I think in the
interview I tell you exactly how I see
nice crime it started when I was a young
PC I became a victim of it I then went
to the country in the government to try
and stop my colleagues and the public
being stat or certainly making sure that
we had the
detective equipment and the Colts
actually increased the sentences to give
a deterrent and it's out of control 15
20 25 years it's not got better it's not
been a fad it is now a reality of life
on the streets of London and many others
in Britain before we wrap up the into
book probably got about 10 minutes I
wanted to address the race issue because
you brought up a number of times and you
and I talked previously about this just
breakdown for people why is there the
perception that stop and search is a
racist policy why is there the
perception that the police target and
mystery ethnic minorities why is there
the sense in some quarters that the
police treat people of different ethnic
backgrounds differently we do it we deal
with everybody on the crime that they
come in now the type of crime that a
number of young black kids commit in
London are street robberies and these
are often at noise point so you're
saying they commit that crime more than
other ethnic groups yes certainly
certainly with it within London but you
think got to say okay who's gonna deal
with that crime well you've got the
police the police have to deal with that
crime is something we can't ignore and
because it's something we can't ignore
we're interrupting their criminal
behavior and when we act when we're
interrupting people's criminal behavior
they don't like it they're not gonna be
cooperative some are I'd stop probably
two or three thousand young black lads
and white lads as well in my 31 years
and one of the myths that everybody sees
and they can't quite work out is why so
many black children are stopped and
searched more than why well here's an
example that nobody ever thinks of and I
know is this when I was in a robbery
squad and we were told seven black use
as robbed someone in Warwick Road London
for example I would attend there with my
team in an unmarked police car the area
would be flood
with with uniform cars area cars
response cars blues and twos we get
description from the witness and the
victim and often it will be somebody was
wearing a duffle coat
you know hoodie whatever it is a band le
you name it so when we're attending
these areas that are highly ethnic areas
we will see people that fit the
description how often if someone said
they all look the same
whoever they are they all look the same
in that particular area well when you're
a police officer going in there you are
looking and you're thinking well he fits
a description don't as so does he and
the other thing what the public don't
always know is that when a robbery is
committed by a gang they swap clothes so
the descriptions on some are different
so we stopped as many as we can
a there could be a suspect be to speak
to them to see who they are where they
where they have been that is our job and
I make no apologies that is the job that
the public expects us to do and we need
to do but the thing is under the police
and Criminal Evidence Act for stop and
search we have to write down everybody
that we have stopped so just suppose in
that incident
we have stopped 40 people 50 people all
the officers made their notes they go in
to admin that thing goes on to the
statistics but during the course of that
day there was 14 or 15 burglaries within
that borough or elsewhere but because
the householder was out we weren't
called to that burglary it was being
committed they got the goods they had it
on their toes so when they come home
they phoned the police and say in those
days we used to attend every burglary
and they said we've been burgled look
they've done this I'll dear me do
dreadful things that are burglary victim
fields we knock on a neighbor's door we
make a few inquiries we get some CCTV
there was three white youths hanging
around outside there was two white used
somebody said I saw none of them will be
stopped and searched we will try and get
photos we will put intelligence out of
the clothes that they wear for them to
be stopped at a later date but that day
seven or eight robberies might have
taken place involving one
to seven to twelve black suspects and we
flood the area every time because it's a
999 call any unit available and that is
often why the number of stopping
searches are high they're also saying
young black men go to prison for or
youth custody for longer than white
people
well the types of crimes that we arrest
them for such as street robbery with a
knife or where someone has been
seriously injured is worthy of a serious
stiff sentence and let me just finish
off by saying this forget about the
black forget about the white let's talk
about prisons we're often told by the
government so we've got too many people
in prison well let me tell you the two
types of people that are in prison those
that commit serious crime murder
firearms offenses rapes stabbing
somebody it's right that they go to
prison to punish to deter and reassure
the public that is what is important the
second type of people or group of people
that go to prison are those that have
exhausted all of the alternatives to
imprisonment from a verbal warning right
up to a suspended sentence and many
calls bend over to contortionism not to
send people to prison but like the first
one people have to be deterred the
people have to be punished other
offenders have to be deterred the public
has to be reassured so they're the two
types of people that go to prison and if
they're the two types of people that a
magistrate or judge themes have
committed such a serious crime or such
persistent crime that the public need to
be protected from them how can we have
too many people in prison the true
answer is this is that the government
and the criminal justice system despite
all of the introductions of a plethora
of community sentences have failed to
find anything that works other than
prison imprisonment and
we're looking at not sending people to
prison for offenses up to six months
we have no policing on the streets to
effectively peace police if you're
stabbed or shot we will find officers to
come there so when you first ask me the
question at the beginning of this
interview why is Britain in chaos as far
as law and order is concerned I'm
privileged to probably be the single
person in Britain that has the unique
job of being able to speak up on
policing victims and the public and if I
would love to be here telling you that
things were far more rosier than they
are but they're not all of the things
that I've told you are from my heart
they're the truth you can challenge me
and I'm one of these people I know I'm
not slick and smooth pink and fluffy I
tell you the facts and I tell you the
truth as I see them and I have a wealth
of experience in over 10,000 media
interviews it's clear that the media and
the public want to hear what someone
like me says and I often tell you what
tens of thousands of frontline police
officers Conn senior officers never do
but the public and victims want to so in
conclusion we can make a difference we
can take the streets back and we need
someone with a passion and a vision
leadership and someone that can actually
stand and look at the battle ahead
without getting distracted and I haven't
seen anyone that I can really believe
has got those skills it's a very serious
boris is not going to be there Boris is
not that man the to finish off with if
we've got two minutes yeah all those
years ago when I woke wrote to the Queen
I'm just a normal bloke but I've been
gifted with a vision and when I wrote to
the Queen five-page letter hardly other
media covered it I went to Buckingham
Palace and I said that gun crime will be
out of control within two years and
committed by children it was on the 13th
of December just couple of years later
2000 or four I predicted that we were
going to have a knife crime epidemic in
Britain and that we needed to act and do
something about it and I wasn't able to
ignite the public interest that got huge
media coverage in a double-page spread
in nearly every sort of first the
national newspaper and on the Sundays I
hold the red top's it was but nothing
ever ever changed and here we are 25
years on and I told you about the
history of what's happened we predicted
at the Police Federation when Teresa may
accuse the Police Federation of crime
wharf that things were getting out of
control everything I've said everything
the Police Federation that represent the
whole Police Service has said has come
true and we now have 22,000 less police
officers to do anything about it I can
put a pressure from my angle as I can on
the establishment on what they need to
do but they don't listen to people like
me they like to listen to people that
they control but I can leave on a
positive and that's this is that for the
last 10 or 15 years I've been working on
a 10-year plan to revolutionize and turn
the criminal justice system round
because I've spoken about it in the
media the government some MPs Sadiq Khan
have all talked about a 10-year plan the
trouble is none of them know what the
10-year plan is they just have seen it
and I've had a pop at them and on social
media saying that we need the 10 year
plan well I've got three of the top
retired homicide detectives in Britain
there are the trustees of the Law &
Order foundation that I have set up and
I've got a vision of a 10-year plan on
engaging with the types of children and
use that I've discussed throughout of
this interview and also that we need a
national resource center in Britain
where victims of crime and the public
have got an independent organization
that campaigns and represents them we
also need to build probably five or six
respite locations in Britain for
families who have been briefed by
homicide at the time of the murder often
the scene may be at home so that is the
crime scene they can go somewhere
pretrial some families just need to get
away because of the trauma of the trial
that's coming ahead you know the
post-mortem results the six to eight
12-week trial ahead somewhere to go or
post trial or any time thereafter so
they can 52 weeks of the year there are
people in Britain have had somebody
murdered that can get away from their
environment and be in a respite location
I can interact with tens of thousands of
retired police officers
many of them are experts on family
liaison and will be there to help them
and the long term vision which I'm
pretty excited about but will cost
billions and people say normal you need
fifty or a hundred thousand to start off
with that's what we need the big project
that I want to see within 10 years is
every major region in Britain has got a
unique massive multi-purpose community
center so these youngsters can get away
at every school holiday maybe 500 or a
thousand a time that are monitored or
nurtured with role models with mentors
with retired police officers bank
workers that want to work with youth
projects and London go to Wales Wales go
to Scotland Scotland go to Cornwall
you're with me every school holiday and
these are super community centres with
accommodation and outside school
holidays they used
the community projects every day of the
week
the kids I've spoken to you about the
use that have got no value of life they
will lose theirs or take somebody else's
if they're the types of people that are
going to give the next generation the
type of generation and the types of
experiences they've had what hope have
we got for the future so what is the
plan of the law-and-order foundation its
massive but I've got a passion as bigger
now as I did all those years ago when I
nearly got murdered
is we need to cut the fuel off to the
young criminals that are carrying knives
and guns and blight in people's lives
we're not going to stop them all but we
can stop a lot turn them away let's get
them let's get mentors let's give them
something positive to do let's
concentrate on the others that won't
learn their lessons and let's make sure
that people can live in their houses
walk the streets travel on transport
knowing if they're a victim of crime
there will be police officers that will
turn up that will listen to them we
won't always make the arrest
but at least they know that their plea
for help has been heeded without these
extra 22,000 and I think it should be
32,000 I'm afraid we've got a long long
struggle so I will continue to fight the
good fight and often enough I often feel
as I'm on that battle line on my own
just imagine if I told you on that
Monday if we can get the whole country
just to concentrate on that one issue
and this is where the this is where MPs
and the rest of them can learn make one
promise to the public and keep it rather
than making dozens and keeping none and
you might be find yourself a very
popular part political party and
politician we might even see a happening
if ordinary people are watching this are
listening to this how can they get
involved with a Law & Order foundation
and help you they can follow us on
Twitter I'm at Norma Brennan but it's
also law order found they will find that
on Twitter as well and
it's time really for everybody that
really says I wish somebody could do
something you can it's you is you we can
all make an effort I mean I have got a
passion and I've got a vision and I'm a
leader I'm a businessman now myself
outside the police
I've always led by example and I know
that we could turn the criminal justice
system round I believe that we can turn
around the perception of crime the fear
of crime and the reality of crime and we
can actually start making the streets of
Britain safer but the longer we blame
someone else for the problems that we're
all partly responsible for the longer
it's going to take and it's a bit like a
wound you put an elastic lasso over a
gaping wound it's going to fester and
it's not gonna it's not going to heal
well you actually put the investment in
to get in that wound cleaned steward
rested nurtured with the follow-up
treatment that wound at the end of the
day you still see it there but that will
that will heal much quicker if the
government invests in policing and then
in the criminal justice system and we
have magistrates and judges to actually
start carrying a bit more for the safety
of society and for victims of crime
rather than becoming social workers and
making excuses why they don't punish and
deter young offenders and other
offenders from committing crime I'm
afraid we've got no hope so I always
believe we've got hope we must always
look for that shot alight and believe
you me I've been on their knees at time
I know what it's like to be in absolute
despair but the thing is when you go to
bed one day and you feel [ __ ] there's
many people out there that have got up
that felt [ __ ] the day before or the
week before they're woken up and said I
feel a bit positive today and the more
that you get more and more people going
a bed feeling [ __ ] but the next day they
get up feeling more positive because
they can actually see a Britain where
they actually will feel safe they will
know that if they're a victim of crime
there will be police they
for them and they know that it will
never be a perfect world even if we
don't Nick them at least if we turn up
and they are felt to be important which
they all are victims are important why
is it we only turn up for the offenders
and we rarely ever turn up if at all for
the victims that's not what I joined the
police service about and that is not
what the criminal justice system is
about either got time for one more
question we always have yeah absolutely
in Norman what is the one thing that
we're talking about that where we really
should be talking about I think if I was
to give a message to the people of
Britain he's wake up from your apathy
you're all concerned you all want
answers there are answers out there I'm
concerned like you are but the more that
you leave your head buried in the sand
the bigger the problem is going to be
and the longer it's going to take to
make sure that the streets of Britain
are safe once again though they used to
be Britain has always been renowned
throughout the world of having the best
police service and the best criminal
justice system the sad reality is we've
gone down there we've gone down the
ranks quite a bit and that blue light
that used to shine bright in Dixon of
dock green days okay policing has
changed has almost gone out let's clean
the glass let's make it bright again and
by doing that we can actually make sure
that there are police officers there for
the public the public for the police we
could interact with everybody and
everybody can actually start working as
a team because as I said to you a little
while ago the more we blame someone else
for the problems that we're all partly
responsible for the less we're gonna had
time to concentrate on those that are
blind societies lives well Norman thank
you so much for coming on and talking to
us as always I'm sure you'll agree this
was another great interview very funny
and light-hearted this week I'm joking
of course on what we're really
appreciate your time and I think it's a
very important message so follow Norman
he'll be doing fundraising and you know
if you're watching this and you're an
influential person please make sure you
heed some of the things that Norman has
said to us as you can tell this is
someone who says well
they actually know and think we will see
you in a week from now thank you very
much for tuning in as always
[Music]